previo a las elecciones de medio término
del próximo martes 8 de noviembre le
escuchamos
y un martillo
le dijo a la policía que vino en busca
de Nancy pelosi para secuestrarla
interrogarla
amenazando romperle las rodillas pero
ella no estaba
su marido mi amigo Paul pelosi estaba
solo en casa
el asaltante trató de que secuestrar a
Paul lo despertó
lo quería secuestrar empezó a utilizar
un martillo contra el cráneo de Paul
felizmente por la gracia de Dios por
sobrevivió todo esto sucedió
me es difícil siquiera de decirlo
entró a la casa del asaltante
preguntando Dónde está Nancy Dónde está
Nancy las mismas palabras utilizadas por
la muchedumbre que asaltó el Capitolio
de los Estados Unidos el 6 de enero
cuando rompieron ventanas cuando
rompieron las puertas corrieron por los
corredores buscando funcionarios y
buscaron también
el anterior vicepresidente Mike pence
estaban totalmente locos y repitiendo
todo el tiempo lo que les decía el
presidente la gran mentira de que la
elección del 2020 había sido robada es
una mentira que avivó el odio y la
violencia política en los Estados Unidos
Durante los últimos dos años incluso
antes del 6 de enero vimos trabajadores
electorales y jurados de votación en
distintos estados que fueron amenazados
que recibieron amenazas hasta contra sus
propias vidas en el estado de Georgia
por ejemplo
familias de funcionarios fueron
amenazadas en particular la de un
trabajador electoral
porque no aceptó cancelar los resultados
que daban por
una victoria por 11.000 votos
también está el caso de su madre Ruby
Freeman Quienes fueron
atacados Solamente porque tuvieron la
valentía de hacer su trabajo defender la
verdad defender la democracia esta
intimidación estas amenazas esta
violencia contra demócratas republicanos
y otros funcionarios que solo están
haciendo su trabajo son la consecuencia
de las mentiras
preferidas por poder por ganancias para
alentar la violencia y generar un ciclo
de odio de ira y de violencia
actualmente tenemos que confrontar estas
mentiras con la verdad porque el futuro
de nuestra nación depende de ello
mis queridos compatriotas estamos en un
punto de inflexión un parteaguas
Tenemos que hablar de una sola voz
unificada hablar como país y decir que
no hay cabida para la intimidación de
votantes o para la violencia política en
los Estados Unidos bien sea en contra de
demócratas o de republicanos no cabe
esto en nuestro país nunca
hablé en el Capitolio la sede de nuestra
democracia Yo sé que hay mucho en juego
en estas elecciones de medio término
nuestra economía a la seguridad del
futuro de nuestros niños nuestros
cuidados de salud etcétera todo esto es
importante tenemos desacuerdos opiniones
divergentes
y esto es importante pero hay algo más
en juego y es la democracia en sí
encuestas recientes demuestran que una
mayoría de estadounidense creen que
nuestra democracia está en riesgo está
amenazada ellos también perciben que la
democracia está en juego en los votos
este año por lo tanto hoy quiero
pedirle a todos los estadounidenses
independientemente de su partido de sean
conscientes de la importancia de este
día Tenemos que votar independientemente
de
los
asuntos políticos del momento porque es
el futuro de nuestra Unión que está en
juego tenemos que recordar lo que hemos
sido y lo que estamos en riesgo de ser a
futuro
estimados con ciudadanos la libertad no
es gratuita y requiere nuestra
vigilancia permanente nada es
garantizado con la democracia en los
Estados Unidos y cada generación ha
tenido que defenderla preservarla
escogerla porque esta es la democracia
es una decisión una decisión del pueblo
por el pueblo para el pueblo
seamos claros nosotros el pueblo debemos
decidir si vamos a tener elecciones
libres y justas en las que cuente cada
voto nosotros el pueblo debemos decidir
si vamos a defender una república donde
se acepta la realidad donde se obedecen
las leyes y donde el voto es realmente
sagrado nosotros el pueblo debemos
decidir si va a prevalecer el estado de
derecho o si le vamos a permitir a las
fuerzas de la oscuridad que tanto buscan
el poder poner en duda los principios en
los que creemos desde hace tantas
décadas nuestra democracia
estadounidense está atacada porque el
anterior presidente de los Estados
Unidos se negó a aceptar los resultados
de las elecciones del 2020 se negó a
aceptar la voluntad del pueblo y el
hecho que había perdido
abusó de su poder
Y puso la lealtad hacia sí mismo antes
de la lealtad hacia la Constitución
contó una gran mentira y alentó
a los parques a Los partidarios del
América en el partido republicano la
elección del 2020 ha sido la más atacada
en nuestra historia sin embargo no hay
elección en nuestra historia de la cual
podemos estar más seguros en cuanto a
los resultados cada desafío posible
aconteció cada recuento que se hubiera
podido hacer se hizo cada recuento
confirmó los resultados
cualquiera que sea el hecho o la
evidencia que se solicitó la gran
mentira fue solamente esto Una gran
mentira cada vez ahora los republicanos
del maga están poniendo en duda la
legitimidad de acciones pasadas pero
también las elecciones que van a
acontecer ahora y en el futuro
los extremistas del maga en el partido
republicano que son una minoría en el
partido republicano como lo dije tienen
mucha influencia y están tratando de
tener éxito donde no lo tuvieron en el
suprimiendo el derecho de los votantes y
subvirtiendo el sistema electoral en sí
esto es su derecho al voto y negar que
cada voto cuenta Y en lugar de esperar
hasta después de la elección empiezan
antes empiezan desde ya
con violencia intimidación de votantes y
de trabajadores electorales
hay más de 300 negadores de las
elecciones que son candidatos en las
elecciones este año no podemos ignorar
el impacto que esto tiene sobre nuestro
país esto es sumamente dañino corrosivo
y destructivo ahora Esto no se trata de
mí
en esto se trata de todos nosotros
es lo que hace Estados Unidos la
democracia es más que un solo gobierno
es una forma de ser una forma de ver el
mundo
una forma de definir lo que somos y en
lo que creemos porque hacemos lo que
hacemos la democracia es Sencillamente
lo fundamental por lo tanto ahora
tenemos que conectarnos con nuestro más
profundo anhelo y proteger la democracia
la democracia está del juego y tenemos
que recordar estos primeros principios
la democracia significa el
gobierno del pueblo no el gobierno de
Los Monarcas o del dinero sino el
gobierno del pueblo la autocracia es lo
opuesto de la Democracia significa el
poder de uno
una ideología un partido una persona un
dirigente
las vidas de miles de millones de
personas desde la antigüedad hasta hoy
han sido forjadas en esta tensión entre
la autocracia y la democracia la
aspiración de unos pocos contra el deseo
de muchos el derecho a la
autodeterminación y la búsqueda de
Aventuras personales el sueño de una
democracia y el apetito de la autocracia
lo que estamos haciendo ahora
determinará si la democracia pueda
vivir y yo creo que esta es la pregunta
principal
si los estadounidenses deciden priorizar
el estado de derecho
o no esta es la pregunta esta es la
lucha la lucha por la democracia por la
decencia por la dignidad por la
prosperidad por el progreso una lucha
por el mismísimo alma de los Estados
Unidos no se equivoquen la democracia
está en juego en estas elecciones para
todos y todas nosotros la democracia es
un poder de convocatoria tenemos que
cuidarnos unos a otros vernos unos a
otros como nosotros el pueblo no como
enemigos Esta es la decisión que podemos
tomar esta Unión y el caos no son
inevitables
ha habido rabia antes en Estados Unidos
ha habido división antes pero nunca
abandonamos esta experiencia americana y
no lo podemos hacer ahora lo fantástico
de la Democracia americana es lo
siguiente
la mayoría ha decidido defender la
democracia y esto ha sido suficiente Y
tenemos que escoger este camino otra vez
porque la democracia está en juego
porque hasta en nuestros momentos más
oscuros hay valores fundamentales que
nos unen como estadounidenses y nos
deben unir ahora
primero creemos que el voto en Estados
Unidos es sagrado debe ser honrado y no
obstaculizado debe ser contado no
ignorado debe ser respetado no es una
herramienta partidaria que se debe
contar para ayudar a unos candidatos y
para ignorar cuando no segundo debemos
con una voz unida o ponernos a la
violencia política y a la intimidación
punto Tenemos que hablar en contra de
esta violencia no podemos
permitir en Estados Unidos que se
resuelvan las cosas con una bala con una
muchedumbre Rabiosa o con un martillo
tenemos que usar los votos tenemos que
ser honestos enfrentar este problema no
lo podemos ignorar no podemos pensar que
se va a resolver por sí solo
aumenta de manera preocupante
los ciudadanos estadounidenses
que
condenan o que no condenan la violencia
política o que se quedan en silencio
sino
condenamos la violencia política
no podemos avanzar no podemos permitir
que esto se multiplique tenemos que
enfrentar confrontar la violencia
política ya mismo yo estoy convencido
que las voces que alientan a la
violencia en la intimidación
corresponden a una minoría en los
Estados Unidos pero
se pero hablan muy duro y están muy
determinados tenemos que ser
determinados
tenemos que rechazar la intimidación
contra los votantes yo creo que la
mayoría de los estadounidenses creen en
esto tenemos que dejar muy claro que la
violencia y la intimidación no tienen
cabida en los Estados Unidos y tercero
creemos en la democracia es lo que somos
como estadounidenses
No ha sido fácil la democracia es
imperfecta siempre lo ha sido pero todos
y todas debemos defenderla ahora la
historia y el sentido común nos dicen
que la libertad la oportunidad y la
justicia
crecen en la democracia y no en la
autocracia
por supuesto
la sociedad estadounidense no es una de
perfecta igualdad
pero la promesa del sueño americano es
suficientemente grande para que todos
puedan tener éxito en cada generación la
puerta de la oportunidad se abre un poco
más y nuevas
nuevos ciudadanos participan de nuestra
sociedad incluso los que han sido
excluidos antes no podemos dejar a nadie
atrás todos somos hijos e hijas de Dios
y cada persona es Sagrada si esto es la
verdad entonces cada derecho también
debe ser sagrado la dignidad individual
el valor individual la determinación
individual estos son los Estados Unidos
Esta es la democracia que debemos
defender
ahora estoy hablando y 27 millones de
personas ya han expresado su voto en las
elecciones de medio término y muchos
otros votarán de aquí al 8 de noviembre
y por primera vez
y es la primera vez desde la elección
Nacional del 2020 estamos viendo una
participación
récord en todo el país y esto es muy
dispositivo queremos que voten Los
Americanos queremos que cada voz de los
Estados Unidos sea escuchada tenemos que
seguir con este proceso sabemos que cada
más votos se reciben ahora por correo en
los Estados Unidos y sabemos que muchos
estados no empezarán a contar estos
votos sino hasta que cierren los puntos
de votación el 8 de noviembre lo cual
significa que no conoceremos al ganador
de las elecciones sino hasta unos días
después del 8 de noviembre se demora
contar todos los votos de manera legal y
organizada siempre ha sido importante
para los ciudadanos en las democracia
disponer de información Ahora les
pedimos que también sean pacientes
porque así funcionan las cosas
también es la primera elección desde los
eventos del 6 de enero cuando una
muchedumbre Rabiosa asaltó el Capitolio
nacional
Quisiera poderles decir que al asalto
contra la democracia terminó ese día
pero lamentablemente no puedo Hoy hay
candidatos en todos los niveles
gobernadores procurador general
secretario de estado etcétera que no se
van a comprometer a aceptar los
resultados de la elección en la que
ellos mismos son candidatos
hay un riesgo de caos en los Estados
Unidos esto no tiene precedentes es
ilegal y es contra los está contra los
valores de Estados Unidos no podemos
solamente querer nuestro país cuando
ganamos
este año
no es un año ordinario por favor
reflexionen bien acerca del momento en
el que nos encontramos
en un año normal no tenemos que
enfrentarnos con preguntas de la
preservación de la Democracia por medio
de nuestros votos pero este año esta
pregunta sí es vigente Y espero que
tomaran en cuenta el futuro de nuestra
democracia en su decisión de Voto Espero
que se preguntarán para qué candidato
quieren votar
esta persona aceptará la voluntad
legítima del pueblo de los Estados
Unidos
esta persona aceptará el resultado de la
elección que gane o que pierde la
respuesta a esta pregunta es vital y yo
creo que debería ser decisiva la
respuesta a esta pregunta es la que
determina el futuro del país que tanto
queremos y el futuro de nuestra
democracia que tanto nos ha dado
Hay demasiadas personas que han
sacrificado demasiado desde hace
demasiados años para poner en peligro y
sacrificar el proyecto de democracia
hemos disfrutado de nuestras libertades
desde hace tanto tiempo que es fácil
pensar que siempre las Pero oye esto ya
no es cierto en nuestros huesos sabemos
que la democracia se encuentra en riesgo
y también sabemos
que está en nuestras manos la
preservación de la democracia y yo creo
que lo lograremos yo creo que conozco
este país Yo sé que la vamos a proteger
ustedes tienen el poder es su decisión
el futuro de esta nación el futuro y el
destino del alma estadounidense está en
sus manos ustedes el pueblo en sus
corazones en sus votos
mis estimados con ciudadanos vamos a
estar a la altura de este momento
recordemos Quiénes somos somos los
Estados Unidos de América no hay nada
nada que se encuentre Más allá de
nuestra potencial y nuestras capacidades
si lo hacemos juntos que Dios los
bendiga a todas y todos que proteja
nuestras tropas y también que proteja la
democracia Muchas gracias
[Aplausos]